c'est une reprise des négociations en
douceur qui se prépare dans la capitale
autrichienne
plus de cinq ans après la signature de
l'accord de vienne américains et
iraniens vont se retrouver
le processus a été élaboré au cours
d'une visioconférence entre
représentants de la chine de la france
de l'allemagne de la russie du
royaume-uni et de l'iran les etats-unis
se disent prêts à lever leurs sanctions
contre la république islamique
si téhéran respecte à nouveau la
limitation de son programme nucléaire
depuis des semaines nous avons
clairement indiqué que nous sommes prêts
à revenir au plein respect de mes
engagements dans le cadre du plan
d'action global conclu à vienne en 2015
si l'iran ont fait autant nous avons
également été transparent sur le fait
que nous avons discuté avec nos
partenaires dans le cadre du p5 + 1 de
la meilleure façon d'y parvenir
y compris à travers une série de mesures
réciproques initial la présence d'une
délégation américaine à vienne a été
acceptée par tous les participants
mais l'iran a déjà indiqué qu'il
refusera tout contact direct avec les
américains
lors de la réunion virtuelle dans le
cadre de l'accord de vienne l'iran et
l'union européenne ont convenu de
reprendre les pourparlers directs à
vienne mardi prochain objectif finaliser
rapidement la levée des sanctions et
l'adoption de mesures sur le nucléaire
pour la suppression synchronisée de
toutes les sanctions suivi par la fin
des mesures correctives de l'iran pas de
réunion iran etats unis pas nécessaire
concrètement deux groupes de travail
étudieront les aspects pratiques de la
levée des sanctions et du retour de
l'iran à la mise en oeuvre intégrale de
ses engagements nucléaires
en parallèle des discussions seront
menées entre les états unis et la
république islamique par l'intermédiaire
du chef de la diplomatie européenne
josep borrell cette reprise des
négociations en présence des états unis
survient trois ans après le retrait
unilatéral américain sous l'impulsion de
donald trump joe biden de son côté s'est
dit prêt à revenir à la table des
négociations à condition que téhéran
respecte à nouveau ses engagements
les iraniens s'en étaient
progressivement a franchi en riposte aux
sanctions américaines imposées en 2018